maman
ta beauté se doublait d'une extrême
réserve de comportement particulièrement
saisissante dans un environnement où
prévalait la décontraction de la
jeunesse tes yeux pers dans un village
dans un visage éclairé refléter le vécu
d'une tragédie indélébile il y avait un
toit
déjà cet ineffable miracle de charme qui
n'a jamais disparu ainsi papattes
décrit-il si justement en deux phrases
synthétique qui souligne son caractère
d'état beauté lorsqu'il te croiser à
l'automne 45 tu ne m'en voudra pas de ne
pas évoquer la carrière professionnelle
et politique qui appartient aujourd'hui
à l'histoire
je laisse cela monsieur le président de
la république que je remercie de sa
présence il ya qu'il reviendra dans
quelques instants de dire ce que tu as
fait pour la france et le cas échéant
pour l'europe
[Musique]
pour ma part et avant pierre françois je
voudrais te remercier de ce compte était
nos relations depuis 70 ans
très tôt me semble-t-il j'ai pris
conscience du vécu de ce que papa nomme
une tragédie indélébile l'absence
remarquable de grands parents ne pouvait
qu'attirer l'attention et susciter mes
questions auxquelles tu répondais
toujours simplement et de manière de
plus en plus détaillée au fil des années
avant l'âge de 10 ans je connaissais le
nom d'auschwitz et le sort des juifs que
les nazis y réserver dans les camps
il est vrai que quelques années
auparavant j'étais rentré en larmes de
l'école maternelle
interrogé par toi je t'avais fait
observer quelle chance nous avions de ne
pas être protestant malheureuses
victimes des massacres de la saint
barthélemy à l'époque rien n'était dit
dans les écoles à propos de la shoah et
tu as dû y suppléer
et puis nous n'avons quand on peut
accompagner à l'occasion de ces réunions
avec les anciens de beau break
ce commando est hors du camp d'auschwitz
où tu as travaillé quelques mois la fin
de l'année 44
je n'ai pas oublié vos conversations à
l'occasion desquelles vous parliez enfin
librement de ce que les autres ne
voulaient pas entendre soit pour les uns
parce que ça les gênait ou les ennuis
hier soit pour vos proches parce que vos
épreuves et vos souffrances leur était
proprement insupportable c'est ainsi que
nous fîmes la connaissance de tes
camarades comme vous dites entre vous
marceline loridan paul shaefer ginette
kolinka qui sont ici ainsi que fagnes et
aulas ait d'autres miraculé et puis il y
eu ce voyage à auschwitz birkenau en
décembre 2004 toi de tes fils et les
plus âgés de tes petits enfants nicolas
n'avait pas eu envie de venir que nous
nous montra le camp des hommes et celui
des femmes
tu nous indiques à les emplacements de
l'hôtel celui des chambres à gaz et des
fours crématoires tu nous expliqua le
voyage dans les wagons à bestiaux avec
les pleurs des enfants
l'arrivée sur la rampe la terreur
provoquée par la violence gratuite des
ss le tri par mangala la tonte des
cheveux le tatouage des numéros faisant
de vous des chutes et le manque de
sommeil
la faim le froid la promiscuité la
saleté l'odeur pestilentielle des corps
qui brûlent les cendres noires rejetée
par les fumées des fours crématoires les
latrines commune seul lieu de quiétude
car déserté par les ss du fait de fait
de l'effroyable puanteur des lieux
le travail d andorre commando l'arrivée
des quatre cent cinquante mille juifs
hongrois au printemps 44 assassiné avant
même d'entrer dans le camp tu nous fuit
les honneurs de ton bloc
barak qui n'a pas été détruite es tu
nous montres à l'accueil à ces schalit
de trois étages constitué de planches de
bois disjointes où vous pouviez à quatre
ou cinq essayer de vous agglutinés pour
tenter de vous assoupir entre les trop
fréquents appels nocturnes tu nous avais
déjà raconté les marches de la mort et
la mort de ta mère que tu adorais et que
tu n'as pas revu en rentrant des travaux
forcés rappelant ceux là on comprend
pourquoi pas par résumait avec l'
extrême pudeur qui était la sienne
la réserve de ton comportement des taux
ton regard comme les stigmates d'un vécu
d'une tragédie indélébile
non je ne pouvais pas être comme les
autres étudiants de sciences po toi qui
avait appris en rentrant des camps que
tu avais été reçus au bachelot dont tu
avais passé les épreuves la veille de
son arrestation à nice en mars 44 et qui
nous a maintes fois dit que tu avais le
sentiment d'avoir été obligé de ré
apprendre à lire
en rentrant des camps tant la tentative
délibérée permanente et savamment
organisée de déshumaniser les déportés
étaient efficaces
de cette tragédie tu as tiré des leçons
pour la vie des camps tu avais gardé
l'horreur de la promiscuité et de toute
familiarité
malgré un scepticisme absolu sur le
comportement des humains que regarder
une bienveillante énergie pourrait t en
toutes circonstances celles et ceux qui
souffrent et nous t'avons vu magistrat
la chancellerie comme ministre tenter de
résoudre souvent avec succès nombre de
problèmes individuels de cette
expérience tu as appris à faire le tri
entre l'essentiel et l'accessoire tant
d'anecdotes ou d'attitude le montre
c'est ainsi que tu attaché moins
d'importance à nos résultats scolaires
en dents de scie
quelle éthique de nos comportements ou à
la qualité de nos réactions une opinion
dont nous devions toujours justifiées tu
as toujours rejeté les idées convenues
léger en permanence était frappé par ton
inégalable et si rassurant bon sens ton
goût pour le débat dont invaincu dont
nous savons qu'il te conduise est
affronté ton père s'est poursuivie tout
au long de ta vie non seulement dans la
vie publique mais aussi dans la sphère
privée y compris de ta famille ton
caractère
certains diraient inexactement son
mauvais caractère et célèbres et
redoutées
je pense que ce caractère il paraît
clair françois et moi en avons hérité
je dirais plutôt que cette détermination
constituent la trame de l'armure qui t'a
permis de survivre à l'enfer
chacun de nous a pu constater la
rapidité avec laquelle l'extraordinaire
regard qui était le tien et que papa et
même temps pouvait passer de la
bienveillance à la fureur puis de la
colère la fiction la plus douce
qu elle mettait parfois que tu étais
soupe au lait aujourd'hui je veux te
dire que je te pardonne d'avoir renversé
sur ma tête alors que nous étions à
table
l'eau de la carafe sous prétexte que
j'aurais tenu des propos que tu trouves
est misogyne
je t'aime maman
[Musique]